カンッ！(音)
（はじめ）実家の富山に帰って来ているんですけども
（後輩）ふふｗ
（はじめ）どうですか富山は？
今からどこに行くかと言いますと
ちょっと、山の方せめておりまして
ほんとなんか、静岡にいると雪がないんで
たまには実家のほうに帰ってちょっとね
雪で遊ぼうかと思っております
まぁええんちゃう
（後輩）ええんちゃう
（はじめ）さぁご覧くださいこの大自然
いかがですかね
ぉーーー…
（はじめ）まぁ…
（はじめ）え、これほんと怖い
（後輩）うわ！やばい、ほら
（はじめ）うわ、やばいて
（はじめ）ちょ、ほらちょ、ほらちょほらちょほら
（後輩）どこ？
（はじめ）人！ほらちょちょこちょ、ちょ、まちょ
はい、ていうわけで雪山に来たんですけども
ソリで遊びたいと
ソリで遊びたいんだが
そもそもソリを持ってきていない
この雪山でソリが手に入るか入らないか
という問題があります
まずは、ソリを探そう
もうワイ、ワイ達の靴もなめきってるからねほんと…ｗｗ
（後輩）なめきってますね
（はじめ）まぁ、でも意外と…
（後輩）ぁあーー危ない！
（はじめ）わーちょっとｗｗｗ
（後輩)あ、滑る
（はじめ）まずは、あそこに行こうぜ
（なんかの音）ピンポーン
（はじめ）休憩所だな
（後輩）行きましょう
（はじめ）スキーセンターにひょっとしたら
売っているかもしれないからな
（後輩）ひぇｗ　これ登るんですか？
（はじめ）これねｗ（後輩）ｗｗ
（後輩）ちょｗ
ちょっ待ってｗ
早いｗ
ちょｗｗ　危ねえｗ
速い…
（子供）うわぁぁぁぁぁ！！！
（はじめ）ふははｗ
めっちゃ嬉しそうだなｗ
ちょっ助けてぇ！？
（はじめ）助けて？ちょっと
（子供）やばーー！！
（子供）どうしたん？
（はじめ）ふっはｗ
（はじめ）めっちゃ馬鹿にされてるｗｗｗ
（子供たち）ﾌｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊﾊﾊﾊｗｗｗｗｗ
（はじめ）怪我しないように気を付けるんだぞ
（子供)え、寒くないー？
（はじめ）寒くないよ
（子供)え！はじめしゃちょーや！！！
（はじめ）はぁｗテンションｗ
(はじめ)ﾅｲｯ↑んだよぉ...
(はじめ)ソリないのかなぁ...
(子供)あー１・２年生..
(はじめ)が持ってるかもしれない？
はい。
ﾊﾊｗちょっとまｗ
(後輩)速攻ですねｗ
(はじめ)すげぇなぁ...
(子供)ﾖｯｼｬｧｧｧ↑ｗｗｗｗ
(子供)ねぇはじめしゃちょー！
(子供)はじめしゃちょー！×２
(はじめ)うわぁー！
(はじめ)うわぁー！おいっバカバカ！
(子供)はじめしゃちょー！×３
(はじめ)うわぁー！おいっバカバカ！バカッ！ｗ
はじめしゃちょー！×４
バカバカッ！シー！
はじめしゃちょー！×５
バカッ！シー！
(子供)俺サインもらった！サインもらった！
(はじめ)バカバ、内緒、バカヤロバカヤロをいっちょっと待った待った
(はじめ)広めるんじゃなぁい！！
(子供)ﾋﾛﾒﾙﾝｼﾞｬﾅｲ!!ｼﾞｬﾅｧｲ!!
(はじめ)やめろ！やめっｗちょっとｗｗｗ
(子供)ねーねー手に書いてー？
(はじめ)手に書くの？
(子供達)ｳﾊﾊﾊﾊｗｗｗ
(子供)手に書いてー！
(子供)ありがとうございました！
(はじめ)うぉしっ、みんな内緒ね！
(子供達)はい。
(はじめ)怪我しないようにね！
(子供)はい！
(はじめ)行ってらっしゃい！
(はじめ)行ってらっしゃい！あ…
(子供)ﾜｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰｰ!!!!
(子供)ﾏﾀｱｵｳﾈ!
(はじめ)またねー！
(後輩)ちょっ、ちょっちょっちょ！
(はじめ)やばい…
(はじめ)ちょっちょっちょ急…
(はじめ)ちょ
(子供達の奇声)
(後輩)あー危ない！
(子供達)ばいばーーーーい！！
(はじめ)ハァジメシャチョーー！！
ゥワーーーーー！！
内緒ね内緒ねー
ワカッタァーーーー！！
ハジメシャチョーーー！！ｗ
全然分かってないよｗｗｗ
あのー、元気で良かったね
ソリもくそもないぞ、もうこれ
一回ソリ探しに行くか
一応雪山、他の雪山に着いたんですけど
雨がひどすぎるね
ほんと無理じゃない？これだってさー
もう嫌やわぁ
(後輩)これダメですねー
(はじめ)ダメだねー
これだけ雨降ってるとさぁ
せっかく来たのにさぁ
(後輩)もう…無理そうですねー
(はじめ)無理だねー
雪じゃないもん
たぶんこれだと、
ソリしてもたぶん、雨が降ってて滑んないから
こんな中じゃさすがに無理だよ
もうソリ無理！
こんな雨の中のソリなんてほんとに無
♪〜
わーーー！
(後輩)わぁぁぁ
(はじめ)危ない！ぐは…
ゴゴゴゴゴゴゴ…(吹雪く音)
(後輩)ぬっ！
(はじめ)わーっ、あーーっ！
あーっ！
あーーーーー！
あーーーー！
あ゛ーーーー！
(後輩)あーははｗｗｗちょｗｗｗ
(はじめ)まっ…○%&×■…
(後輩)ちょっ、ソリが！ソリが！
ゴゴゴゴゴゴゴ…(吹雪く音)
(はじめ)あっ…見えない！
¥#▽〆＊$…おいっ！
ゴゴゴゴゴゴゴ…(吹雪く音)
はーっ、はーっ、はっ…
♪〜